my apologies or emergency announcement
is the first thing so I'll read it
through so is in the event of a fire or
other emergency please exit the building
in an orderly manner to the assembly
point which is located in the market car
block the fire exit in this represented
by green fire exit sign please do not
delay the evacuation by clicking any
belongings and do not use the lift the
premises must not be reinsert until the
fire brigade have given the all-clear
please note it is against the law to
smoke on these premises and please also
know this material we are recorded so
thank you very much members write
apologies for ever it was that one all
no goals can you make sure your mobiles
are either solid or off please rubble
they serious
police arrested so don't think there are
any no members attending nothing
counselor Shore is invasive welcome and
I say welcome to members of the puppy
pleased to see you here
administer the meeting held on the 6th
of December is it your wish that I
signed them as true record thank you any
declarations of interest if there are
any further declarations that come along
during the course of the meeting please
say them then am I sure they're included
minutes right so item 5 his masters
refer to the executive reports from
other committees we've got a report the
Investment Board which is item 5 go to
that one if we came
lost it
young Knights of five so this is report
of the of the Investment Board okay
Carrie please I think really has dr.
Laurel throughout to say you've all read
the duck the paperwork and her all the
documents really is a place if there's
any questions that you've got with
regards to the paper and the cell phone
actionable do our best Watson members
will have seen this with the papers for
the investment wolf that came along just
sayin chairman the you know I was an
observer at the investment board nothing
most of the questions that could have
been asked were asked at the investment
bald I think is the right move ahead
nothing that was a general consensus of
the investment board in the day to be
honest I don't be as much more twice
right so if there's no other comments
members not the information item 6 which
is the progress on decisions anybody
wants to raise anything on Probie
decisions please you've got four notes
here I know I thought if I'm jumping
about in this one this all six point six
keep community safety hub I just wanted
to ask why if you would like to expand
on that so we get there clarity on
what's happening out of here certainly
happy to can I just add that there
should be changed the item six point six
the wording should actually be the
adjoint watch of district cast point
Community Safety hub is implemented
involving the relocation of the
councillors Community Safety Officer
rather than that the watcher district
Community Safety hub is implemented at
voting police station just be noted
please as the hub will actually be
taking place named castle point officers
not okay yeah thank you thank you um so
yes there have been delays with hub
itself unfortunately had correspondence
with Chief Inspector John Wesley
yesterday he says apologies at the time
scars have slipped again difficulties
particularly with the IT from the
police's perspective they are very keen
for it to go ahead it will happen will
be based and also point officers as acts
felt to be the best location or the best
area has 24/7 access to the building but
unfortunately he is still waiting for HQ
and assistant Chief Constable traffic to
give a steer on the actual time frame so
he's going to happen but unfortunately
it is being held up by the police again
like Owen there's an Amber marking on it
at the moment so hopefully on the next
time we see this we should know exactly
yes I'm clips images oh yes look further
just a bit of informative I believe that
the offices are going to be going to
tablets at some time is there any news
on that or is that again part of the IT
whole Bank and part of the IT hole back
in terms of UNITA project but that is
happened and something I know what your
host husband has spoken about the new IT
that's coming for the police themselves
but when I'm when I'm given further
information on how to update on that
sooner the better I think that any other
points members please
once I'm in denote the report right
thank you
so item 7 which is the financial
management performance report digital
speakers please comment I'll make is
over sir no I mean you can see the
overall picture is is appearing to be
quite quite rosy with a forecast of some
savings against budget budget settings
but it's it's not a figure to get
complacent over that figure represents a
lot of hard work and creating
efficiencies it creates a result of
innovative ways of working new ideas
being put forward and in one or two
cases staff working extra hard covering
absences illnesses maternities and so on
so while it is a positive figure and it
is a step in the right direction towards
the real challenges of next year and
forthcoming years nevertheless it should
be taken as a as a positive result from
resulting from the hard work of a lot of
people in a lot
but Hanna detail on Passover tune home
maybe yes counselor Smith mentioned the
underspend to the period up until the
end of December has increased by just
over 3,000 pounds which we're reporting
at 42 and there's a couple of main
reasons for that the salaries under
Spence that we spoke about has not
really changed but there's been some
additional and income from planning fees
that's come in and there's also been an
accounting adjustment in terms of some
commitments are expected to happen this
year to now do not expect it to happen
so I've been written back out the
accounts so they're the two main changes
from the quarter two positions about for
those sort of one-off factors which will
necessarily be expected for you to
repeated going forward I would just add
in terms of the relation to the futures
budgets as well that some of the unspent
of seeming commentary this year in
relations and salaries under spend and
accounts to tack showing income have now
been factored into the proposed budget
for next year obviously subject to
agreement and local council next week so
again we wouldn't expect lights to be
occurring in future years based on the
current information so they have been
factored into a sort of ongoing budget
and so yeah it's a positive story in
terms of the position for this year we
all plan to use some of those under
spensive sooner so that year end to
decide for some specific reserves to
support and
and things such as the homelessness
patients where there's still some risks
and also rather certain practices say
anything there's not Podesta specific
reserved a year-end would then be encode
for dispositive the general balance just
to mention on the capital program that
spend today on capital so far this year
is pretty much all profiles what would
expect and the forecast thinking that
then the capsule program will be nearly
on line it by the end of the year maybe
interests a slight span under delivery
but it's pretty pretty much contracted
to deliver what we set out as you
noticed and as usual that there's a
performance indicators also at the end
of the report and so I think that's what
I was going to say and this new eyes for
any specific questions around the area
just if I may just to stop a robbery
there's a couple of anomalies within car
parking income I don't know I think you
were gonna look into something yeah you
I think one of them is around
it's an old ship plane because it seems
to more than double
and of course Webster's way which is
this way yeah I spoke with Marcus
Haughton today and we found that they
easter bank holidays for 2017 we're in
April therefore these shows up in these
2017-18 financial year same with these
two bank holidays in 2016 were in March
it showed up in the financial year for
1516 so from a tech it's really
technical the other points which were
highlighted was the the weather
conditions the three days in December
there's a
and a drop in income of 15,000 pounds so
the overall estimate for so the overall
estimate 42,000 pounds is assigned to
the incremental weather conditions so I
don't think we need to sort of worry
about the figures at this point I think
we'd better to actually look at the year
in figures rather than the pro-rata yeah
but I think the income is slightly down
but doing that that's the way of these
things very often exactly I joke oh
there was mainly due to the public
holidays
I'm putting into the new financial year
thank you very much any other questions
please for the report as I say it's
extremely hard thing to see the overall
financial initiative we managed to
achieve this year against targets
hopefully that will be sustained in the
last quarter because we should see but
to be what we're talking about the
variance there six hundred and forty
four thousand in our favor against the
budget position just over nine million
isn't it so that's you know there's a
ratio that's pretty good and as long as
they're not something that's short on
anything I know that we're doing that I
think there's reason to be the staff
survey as well
forward to the results of that yeah just
to make sure that we're actually running
a good service and then the star for
January happy with the staffing levels
that we have I mean there'll ever be
really happy because we do try them a
little bit if you like that anybody
would because it's probably money we're
looking at this nice result coming throw
shortly so you can suspend you
thank you Jim we had our bimonthly
meeting with Suez today and I think it's
reasonable to report that both parties
interested to try and improve on the
efficiencies of of the contract both
from our point of view and sewers you
know we're all working in the same
direction we have a common out I'm the
common goal I think you know hopefully
over the next few months you will see an
improvement in in both efficiency
cleanliness and the way that sewers are
operating in junction with us
congratulations by the way I think we're
countrywide we're number two on we point
one percent behind the next one
yeah we've got another one it wasn't the
usual colbry was something from black
women so much somewhere oh yeah yeah so
you know that's an interesting one but
it's fantastic I think you know our
staff do a great job with soda sewers on
that but I think the main people who do
the work on that we've got to recognize
are the public because they're the ones
who actually do the sorting do the
recycling yeah and actually take part in
what we do and they're the enthusiasm
there is fantastic I don't think a thing
is chairman that we say we almost take
it for granted I mean we've been in the
top five for uh I don't know how many
years now I'm at least it's we accepted
as the norm the bigger issue that we've
had is to with new people moving into
the area to so educate them as to how
the system works once I get the hang of
it it's funny it was in a Simon please
yes it's just a comment really is
going to show but we're sort of actually
shine without standing fiscal management
you know we'll be out of our residents
you know where we're going forward and
being able to show these type of figures
and the way we manage continuous
services and the various things that
we're doing at the moment I don't think
it's it is very very good thank you very
much so the agreement so Jared you did
mention it's public money and I think
it's worth just formally noting that we
know this is public money and the
prudence and care that we take in
managing your budget and managing this
council is very important and this is a
result of that absolutely yes we
disapprove that at all
are there any other questions everybody
wants this one so thank you know me for
that Simon right so we note the revenue
and budget capital position and and we
revenue financial indicators exam three
thank you so now to item 8 on this one
as you may know I've been in discussions
together with some of my colleagues and
offices with other South Ethics
authorities relating to how we continue
with our planning people into the future
and how they all relate together
I think that's something that's not
really been done properly before so this
is new ground for us so we've got seven
authorities involved and of just us as
per the reports and it's as well and we
we tried to prepare a vision for the
whole of South Essex the reason we're
doing this is because we want to make
sure and as a body as a South hissings
body we can leave her in some of the
investment there other areas are getting
in
infrastructure when I say infrastructure
we're not just talking about roads we're
talking about other infrastructure as
well as police education etcetera et
cetera and all of the authorities are
involved in this always speaking as one
we meet regularly discuss it and we need
to make sure that we follow the national
product planning policy framework we
have all authorities are struggling with
their local plans and this will also
assist those authorities which are three
within the South Essex to make sure that
they can sort of square that circle if
you like taking it forward and as far as
rocks with is concerned things like the
a one to seven where we've recently had
the announcement about the twenty six
million that's going into the and it's
being consulted on at the moment about
the fair fairly around the bow etc and
the environs of there it's great news to
hear that that money's coming forward
and that things are actually going to be
done around our area that we don't bust
not just us but some of their neighbors
as well and help the overall picture so
that's the sort of thing that we're
trying to leave her in by taking forward
this and to assist that we've done a
Memorandum of Understanding which is not
a legal govern a legal document it's
purely just what it says it is it's a
memorandum understand it doesn't bind us
to anything but it does mean that we're
all trying to work together to achieve a
name and we've certainly had it's a very
great interest from an Eleanor DCG
anymore it's da children whatever what
they call it but as I say it's it's
great you know I think it's the only
game in town for us as far as this is
concerned it will assist hopefully going
forward some of our planning decisions
in our local plan as well as outcome for
comes forward of course these things are
not done overnight
what we're looking at at the moment with
our local plan is purely a consultation
on those planning land areas that have
been forward by the public by business
and land owners which is the you know
victory at the beginning of the
beginning of our local plan it certainly
doesn't mean to say that we're going to
be order them by any means that that's
going intending as some of this work as
well and with all the other authorities
so I'm happy to take any questions I
don't know anybody else what's out there
know if you want to say anything Shawn
no I mean other than other than the fact
that you know just to reinforce the
point you make about cooperative working
because I think that what's clear is
that is that this is an ambition that's
coming directly from government and I
think we anticipate that the national
planning policy framework will be
adjusted in the very near future there's
it's likely that a new version will be
published at fit fairly soon and that
will include at the moment we have a
duty to cooperate but I think what the
government is looking at is is the
preparation of a statement of common
ground that local authorities
neighboring local authorities will need
to sign up to and really the work that's
been taking place in South Essex is in
some small measure a precursor of that
change in the in the NPP f that's right
I think you can really see that under
3.1 on the report on the first page of
the
to generate its on detailees in your
introduction chairman you you mentioned
the the a one through seven only the
work of a Glennon interchange and I
think that that is a good news story
it's important that we cooperate with
all the different parties involved in
delivering that because that is going to
be a benefit for our residents and I
think the the cooperation and clarity
that this understanding will give will
perhaps help stop some of these silly
political games that some people have
been playing to intimidate our residents
by threatening things like congestion
charging on the a12 seventy which is
wholly untrue so I completely welcome
this as a way to give clarity to to our
residents and help us be involved in
positive things for our district and to
stop some of the silly games taking
place thank you thank you yeah yesterday
thank you very much chairman no I just
like that Hey
so what simon has just said in as much
as that the long-term planning and this
is something that you know we're doing
something that's not been done here
before and i think that's a very very
important factor but what we're actually
trying to do is to give confidence and
reassurance to you know investors to
residents or what the future can be
because i think a long-term view is
something that we no one's really looked
at we are now looking at that to give
reassurance for developers for everybody
and investment coming in especially for
health well-being skills and all those
things that we need within our area and
most important as you stand right at the
very beginning a vast amount of
infrastructure not just roads but sewage
water broadband everything agree and I
think some of this work will actually
make sure that that's what
yes I'm accessible it is planned at the
margin to act as a local plan in
isolation is all very well but of course
people travel outside their borders and
that's what we've got to look at and
it's about cooperation between all
authorities
and of course not forgetting Essex
County Council is absolute paramount in
that and I think there as Sean says
there will be some compulsion from
government for us to do that in any of
it but as I say these aren't plans are
going to come overnight these are
long-term plans we're looking at 2015 no
not 2020 but of course you've got to do
this work in the community by the time
we get to 2050 but probably I'll get
there sir
of course it will be a probably a very
different world to that which really
mean now and of course any plan that
comes forward has got to be a player
that's that's fluid and is a subject to
change in accordance to circumstances
that prevail at that time but you can't
plan anything without actually getting
the information and part of that is the
discussions that are taking place at the
moment and it's very interesting to hear
when I go to these meetings what's
actually going on with our neighbors
because many of our residents actually
don't work in her area at all they
actually work outside of it and they
travel whether it by train
thus for cycle or car and it's very
important for them that we make sure we
can get the better the best facilities
that we gain yes please I've often
referred to as the a 1 to 7 economic
corridor and I think that's how we have
to think of it there's an awful lot of
other things coming forward is low tens
crossing the names of deeply world other
projects that have starting to come to
fruition another access road doctor can
be that will also start to relieve
traffic along the a13 and things like
that
but with regards to 2050 I'll be 96 so I
do plan to see right through
I'll be under 20 I think Mike may tell
he missed out the South End area I mean
we've got the jab in ourselves like
there is so many project wages which is
a major thing for us I think you make an
important point there in as much as
we're key key players we're honest out
there six in those amateurs the airport
when it's environ it's 98 percent of
something like that I think is a cedar
Oxford and of course we've got the
Business Park which is all part of the
joint action area plan with South in we
the planning authority for that looking
at over 7,000 jobs and high-quality jobs
are there we've got areas coming online
Tumi's that already developed there's a
new Jaguar Land Rover sort of sales
pitch that's bigger and these things
actually these days I mean if you
anybody that owns a modern car they've
pretty high-tech things you know you
can't just sort of to do operates a lot
I used to work as a young man doing
Robin it's just not like that anymore
which I suppose it's good for them but
not not so good for us if we want to do
our time servicing but having said that
it's good that we're part of that and
we've got these things actually you in
the Rockford area but we're not ignoring
the green areas either we've got the
country car we've expanded in several
times
planted over 10,000 trees I think
there's something like that it's amazing
what we're doing we've got good plans
for that and a new entrance et cetera
some of which will be paid for by
hopefully the 106 agreements then again
some of the business park etc so we're
utilizing the right thing but we we're
not losing sight of the fact that we do
live in a nice place and people can't
believe you here because it's a nice
place which food really the whole area
is a nice area to live but it's still
got the playground and the facilities
that people need in the modern world and
it's not that far from London
coming on and if you want your ice cream
and chips you can always go to South in
which is a very far away so having said
that if there are no other questions
right so I will read this through so the
decision being recommended so the
progress made by leaders in chief
executive on strategic place shaping in
the preparation of the south at six 2050
vision be noted and endorsed that a
program of further collaboration on key
strategic shape place shaping and cross
boundary planning policy matters be
noted and endorsed the summit ten
thousand eight hundred pounds be
allocated to progress the preparation of
the south physics 2050 vision and
propriety work for a joint strategic
plan that the intent intention to
establish an association of Essex South
Essex local authorities is a ela and the
principles for joint working set out in
the memory round of understanding dated
the 10th of January 2018 be noted and
endorsed all members happy to do thank
you very much that's the last item I do
thank you very much go ahead we've
managed to get it within the hospital so